from brutal gore the god butcher scenes
to thor dancing to abba and the return
of the grand master there's a stack of
deleted scenes and characters in thor
love and thunder yipikai movie lovers
i'm jan and in this video i'm revealing
every scene in character marvel cut from
the fourth thor movie spoilers ahead of
course so take care
christian bale's gore is a creepy
menacing new antagonist in the mcu
though his presence can feel a little
lacking in screen time and in fact
numerous score scenes were filmed that
didn't make the final cut for example
bale described a horrifying scene where
gore after taking possession of the
necro sword cuts away the tattoos on his
head and body that were symbols of his
religion the deleted scene would have
explained the reason for the scars we
see on him later in the movie but it was
removed as it was deemed too extreme for
a family-friendly film and this shot of
gore picking up the sword on a beach
which was in the trailers but not the
final movie could be from that moment
baylor's also revealed numerous actors
he filmed scenes with that didn't make
it into the final film i got to work
with peter dinklage dinklage played
eatri who last appeared in avengers
infinity war when thor came to his home
to ask for a weapon that could kill
thanos that was stormbreaker and i
suspect the reason gore went to visit
eat tree was because the villain needed
stormbreaker to open a portal so he
could reach eternity in the cut scene
etry may have been unwilling or unable
to create the weapon again likely
leading gore to kill him this would have
been quite a sad moment as eatri was the
last of his kind with thanos already
having massacred the rest of his people
300 dwarves lived on this ring i made
what he wanted and he killed everyone
anywhere a scene of gore killing eat
tree might well have been hard for fans
to stomach however it would certainly
have helped beef up gore's screen time
and the reasons for his nickname the
butcher and it also looks like gore
encountered the grand master from thor
ragnarok in the original cut of the
movie as well i got to work with jeff
goldblum he's not in the final film
either the last time we saw the grand
master was on sakhar where he was
attempting to bargain with the rebels
who'd risen up against him i gotta say
i'm proud of you all this revolution has
been a huge success yay us i think it
might have been curious to see how the
revolution had panned out for the grand
master and whether he'd somehow managed
to charm his way out of a very sticky
situation i suspect gore might have
decided to kill him even though he's not
a god for his tyrannical rule on sakhar
doesn't that sound good again as with
eitri showing more of gore could have
really built up belle's villain even
further than in the final film
a scene i think a lot of fans wish had
been included was seeing jane's original
transformation into the mighty thor
footage from the new asgard set shows
there was a scene filmed with a dummy
and puppeteer where jane was floating in
the air and convulsing right next to the
spot where the broken pieces of mjolnir
were on display in the final movie we do
see jane visiting the spot and the
pieces of the hammer activating but we
never got to see what happened next
which presumably involved the hammer
reforming itself and jane becoming thor
for the first time
before russell crowe became the
egotistical and decadent god zeus it
appears he was originally going to play
satan in the movie a marvel concept
artist has revealed that he was
commissioned to create a comedic look
for crowe as satan according to the
artist this version of the devil was
meant to be humorously debauched similar
to zeus in the final movie he was more
concerned with his own pleasures than
helping thor against gore the devil
almost making his first appearance in
the mcu will undoubtedly also add fuel
to all the mephisto theories that have
spawned since one division
natalie portman has also revealed there
were tons of scenes involving jane that
didn't make the final cut and has said
there's a missing period in the film
where we would have seen how jane and
valkyrie got to know each other and
became close although jane dies and goes
to valhalla at the end of the movie
given the rumors of a potential mighty
thor spin-off and how valkyrie said to
jane that she missed fighting with her
sisters and that she also hoped to go to
valhalla one day herself i could see
these two teaming up in the future
and it looks like thor originally spent
more time with the guardians of the
galaxy at the beginning of the movie
this cut scene plays up the idea that
thor just didn't really want to fight
anymore as the guardians charge into
battle while he just turns around and
walks away with a resigned air about him
and thor's deleted voice over from the
first teaser trailer confirms that in
the original movie he was initially done
with trying to be a hero anymore these
hands were once used for battle now
they're about humble tools for peace i
need to figure out exactly who i am my
superheroing days are over a brand new
character played by lena heady perhaps
best known to many as cersei from game
of thrones appeared in scenes filmed for
thor love and thunder which didn't make
it into the final cut possible parts she
could have played were an olympian god
gaur's wife or perhaps valkyrie's
romantic interest given that at comic
con tessa thompson said that as new king
of asgod valkyrie's first order of
business would be to find her queen
whether valkyrie's queen was in the
original script or it was just
thompson's thoughts about her character
at the time though isn't quite clear at
the moment
chris hemsworth revealed in an interview
that there was a full dance scene of him
that didn't make it into the final movie
and it was set to abbas waterloo it also
involved thor shooting lightning out of
his fingertips and it could have been a
fun moment perhaps with shades of
star-lord stance off in the first
guardians movie mixed with shazam's
lightning from my hand scene
as well as gore's deleted r-rated
mutilation scene christian bell has
revealed his original request for taking
the part was that he'd be allowed to
reference aphex twins come to daddy
music video bale wanted to emulate a
character that emerges from a tv set and
performs a horrifying scream bale says
they did film that moment but he
understands that it was probably too
scary for a pg-13 movie and said it
might have had people running for the
exits
gore was also going to have a dance
during his final battle with thor when
he felt like he was about to win and the
scene would have taken inspiration from
aphex twins window liquor and was also
supposed to mirror thor's earlier abba
dance scene by the sounds of it it was
going to be too scary or dark as well
because in another interview bale also
said there was a lot more creepy as hell
stuff but that was perhaps pushing it to
a realm where maybe it wouldn't have
been able to be family friendly
marvel are well known for modifying
trailer scenes to remove potential
spoilers before a movie is released we
saw how thor's missing eye was restored
for the ragnarok trailers and there's a
subtle change in the leaven thunder
trailers made to meek's whiteboard to
avoid revealing spoilers when thor gives
his rousing speech to the asgardians
times like this we need to unite come
together
i'm sorry me it's very hard to get a
rousing speech with the hate noise
what meek has written on the whiteboard
in the trailer is basically what's just
been happening in the scene in the final
film however it's completely different
as the whiteboard has a massive drawings
that reveal a huge amount of the movie's
plot from gore's opening scene to the
guardian's fighting then the gift of the
screaming goat sith losing an arm king
valkyrie dreaming of fighting shadow
royal monsters and even eternity
the screaming goats are a running gag in
the movie though fans are divided on
whether they like them or not
and according to tessa thompson who's
previously said that she's obsessed with
goats she filmed a scene where valkyrie
had a conversation with the screaming
creatures but it didn't make it into the
final cut giant coats look at those they
are wonderful they also scream quite a
lot there's also some clips in the
trailers of deleted valkyrie scenes like
this one where she's licking her sword
during the battle in omnipotent city and
there's another deleted moment for her
board out of her mind as king valkyrie
although a slightly different version
where she's twiddling one of her daggers
did make it into the final cut although
these were just tiny deleted moments i
do wish they'd been a bit more valkyrie
in the final film and less korg in
ragnarok he was fine as comic relief in
a few scenes but in love and thunder it
felt like he was in too much of the
movie and his jokes often didn't land
for me though of course comedy is very
subjective
there are also some more emotional
scenes between jane and thor removed
from the final cut and portman has also
said that there were 20 different
versions of one key scene as you see
lots of stuff ends up on the cutting
room floor even though it is
beautiful brilliant stuff portman also
revealed that there are whole sequences
planets characters and worlds that
didn't end up in the movie the trailers
do have some deleted shots of valkyrie
together with thor and a planet with
what looks like a lot of trash behind
them which might mean they went back to
zakar at some point of course with all
these deleted scenes a lot of fans will
be asking for the ytt cut which
apparently was initially four hours long
versus a final cut of just under two
hours now this four hour cut was never
an actual watchable movie it's just
what's known as the assembly cut which
is all of the main footage which might
make it into the final film before the
director and editor begin trimming it
all down in fact as much as i wish some
things had been in the final movie like
jane's mighty thor transformation more
valkyrie and more gore it's essential
for any movie to trim the fat and cut
out unnecessary subplots so do you think
love and thunder did a good job of doing
that or did it feel like they asked a
bunch of 10 year olds what should be in
a movie and just said yes to everything
which is what taika ytzi said himself
that it felt like when they were
developing the film it's always
fascinating to know why things make it
into a movie and what gets cut out for
better or worse and if you'd like to
discover the horrific original opening
scene of scarlet witch murdering mordo
in doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness tap here for everything that was
deleted from that movie there's also a
link in the video description so how do
you rate thor love and thunder and do
you wish any of these deleted scenes
have been in the final movie let me know
in the comments below and if you enjoyed
this video do leave a thumbs up i really
appreciate it tap left for my full
marvel deleted scenes playlist including
how black widow almost came back from
the dead thanks for watching and hope
you have a marvelous movie-loving week
yupikai movie lovers